welcome to your mom's house
that's huge
I've wanted to I thought I haven't even
seen it so I just want to know because
this is like something that I figured
like you probably need to watch see
where it is so yeah we were so nervous
you know is my official for you of
eating ass okay this is something that I
feel like you need to watch with I think
you need to pay a little better
attention right this is like one of the
courses you didn't do well in in school
you know it was like well there's
something that I'm hopefully it hits you
in the heart
you know you ready what else did you do
this weekend any see any movies or hi so
this video is my official through you
just like twelve of eating a she's this
weekend recently I had the pleasure of
eating ass people have asked me Vanessa
why and I say why not
yeah and I have given lots of thought
into this question and I have decided
that it would be best that I just make a
general review my one experience she's
um I don't know if she to put the music
on for this moment though right first of
all I rate the experience a six point
five out of ten that's not personally I
rated it a six but I gave it some spot
and I think the six point five is more
fitting I just really want you to think
about that on the terms of how enjoyable
it might be for you
mmm-hmm you know dumb dog it's our dumb
dog um I guess I'll weigh out the pros
and cons now
the pros of eating ass are the other
person enjoy it thank you everybody
thank you no one cares about that your
spouse next people another pearl is I
doesn't taste bad most people think that
something to think about bitches down
here it's bad or they think it'll taste
like poop but it doesn't exactly like I
mean that's so dumb Bobby first of all
if you just did it okay if I lick
something that has jelly coming out of
it it's gonna taste it's not gonna be
jelly coming out like a donut that has
the chocolate coming out of it in the
hole and looks like chocolate chocolate
coming out there's no chocolate coming
up the chocolate lives there but it's
not coming out the chocolate it smells
like the container from which it comes
it's you know like when you you keep
something in a bowl or something and it
retains the odors it's how you have to
sterilize it so that it doesn't she's
crazy this person who's telling you
crazy like a day niak like for whatever
reason it just it doesn't taste like
anything there you go so hard to do
chocolate not once so coming off is all
the pros the cons would be I would say
the biggest time is the small it doesn't
smell and how does it taste not taste
good if it smells bad doesn't say it
smells bad she says it doesn't smell
that great
well what come on that's a different
very young on the witness said I can't
it doesn't smell great done tastes good
but that could imply that it smells good
but not great my granny used to cook a
few things it didn't smell great play
sure they taste good that's terrible
you could also ask the person to like
wash their ass real quick before not a
problem it's not a problem and the small
isn't pleasant but the smell is very
bearable I would say there are morning
yeah another time it would be sometimes
this person has not shaved their ass and
that's totally fine I could take care of
that too but if you're not a fan of hair
then you probably won't appreciate how
mortified would you be just if you're
you know older little older parents you
see this video the amount of hair that
could potentially be in somebody's I
think that's it for the cons so
essential are dogs the pros weigh out
the cons thank you omen so you know I
read it at six point five I didn't think
it was that bad at all I was expecting
worse and it wasn't that bad um so now
that we got the review out of the way I
would also like to address something
that I was pretty upset about after this
event happened I was very upset after I
ate ass because of the amount of people
who I've heard say I don't eat us
okay are we done with this this is a
good look into those eyes because she's
looking at you right now okay okay yeah
we can be done but I just want you to
think about it a little bit